ja wieder ist es ein badeunfall wieder
ein badesee und wieder trifft es ein
kind ein fünf jahre altes kind ist in
hannover trunken in einem see der sofa
spielt märchen sie heißt plötzlich war
sie weg am märchen sie in hannover
bemerkte ein spaziergänger am
freitagabend das eines von drei spielen
den mädchen auf einmal verschwunden ist
er wird sofort den notruf kurz darauf
treffen die ersten polizisten einen sie
erkennen den ernst der lage und springen
ins wasser
doch das wasser ist trüb die sicht
äußerst schlecht erst nach zehn minuten
verzweifelter suche kann ein beamter das
mädchen unter der wasseroberfläche
ertasten die retter ziehen sie an land
und beginnen sofort mit der
wiederbelebung wenig später übernimmt
ein notarzt die reanimationsversuche am
see dauern lange
weil immer mehr schaulustige die
maßnahmen beobachten muss die polizei
umstehende wegschicken 52 einsatzkräfte
sind jetzt vor ort
schließlich wird das mädchen mit einem
rettungswagen ins krankenhaus gebracht
dort stirbt sie wenig später
jetzt prüft die polizei ob die eltern
des mädchens ihre aufsichtspflicht
verletzt haben
ja und zu diesem vorfeld zugeschaltet
ist mir jetzt michael bertram ist er als
polizei-sprecher von hannover guten tag
herr bertram sie stehen dort an der
unglücksstelle
wie konnte es zu diesem unglück genau
kommen ja wir haben jetzt ermittlungen
aufgenommen müssen klären wie es zu
dieser katastrophe kommen konnte
wir haben gegen 19 19 15 gestern abend
kenntnis bekommen von einem zeugen das
war wie ein spaziergänger hier in diesem
park und um den see der darauf
aufmerksam geworden ist das von anfangs
drei kindern nur noch zwei sich am ufer
aufhielten
dann geistesgegenwärtig auch begonnen
hat nach dem kind zu suchen im bereich
des sees und natürlich ganz wichtig ein
notruf abgesetzt hat sie sagten gerade
der zeuge ist ein spaziergänger wo waren
denn die eltern der kinder gibt es dazu
erkenntnisse dazu haben wir jetzt noch
keine richtigen erkenntnisse dass es
auch teil der ermittlungen die nun
angelaufen sind seit gestern abend
natürlich wird jetzt geprüft ob es
mögliche verstöße gibt gegen die
einhaltung der aufsichtspflicht das
müssen wir dabei erstmal alles
überprüfen und ermitteln
im raum steht ja auch die frage konnten
die kinder schwimmen oder wurden
schwimmflügel getragen
dazu können jetzt auch noch nichts sagen
sie können sich vorstellen dass war
gestern natürlich auch eine sehr
dramatische situation hier vor ort immer
unter beteiligung von kindern und da
müssen jetzt auch erstmal die befragung
alle laufen bis wir da wirklich kenntnis
haben wie detailliert dass sie sich
alles zugetragen hat herberg angreifer
sollen ja diese sollte sollen diese
hilfsaktion ja auch noch behindert haben
wie war dann die polizeiarbeit für sie
und auch die rettungsarbeit na ja sie
müssen wissen dieser see befindet sich
in einem wohngebiet im sahlkamp es ist
parkähnliche ringsherum es gibt
spaziergänger natürlich auch in den
abendstunden sind noch viele menschen
unterwegs
ich habe nochmal rücksprache gehalten
mit den einsatzkräften und die haben mir
aber gesagt ja es gab schaulustige wie
man das oft hat bei solchen notfällen
bei rettungseinsätzen aber es ist wohl
nicht so gewesen dass käufer tatsächlich
den einsatz und die rettung behindert
haben und beispielsweise zurückgedrängt
werden mussten
polizei kollege konnte er nach etwa zehn
minuten den leblosen körper des mädchens
aus dem wasser ziehen
eine horror vorstellung der einem
wirklich das herz zerreißt wie geht es
diesen polizeikollegen der das mädchen
dort heraus gezogen hat wir konnten
jetzt noch keine direkte rücksprache mit
ihm halten
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich so dass
die beamten speziell geschult sind mit
solchen situationen auch umgehen zu
können regelmäßig begeben sie sich in
extremsituationen bei bestimmten
einsätzen verein dingen natürlich wenn
kinder dabei mit im spiel sind
wir haben viele kollegen die selber
eltern sind kinder haben vielleicht auch
im gleichen alter
und da ist es natürlich auch wichtig
dass wir da rückendeckung geben und den
kollegen zur seite stehen
es gibt bei der polizei eine regionale
beratungsstelle mit geschulten experten
dass
können direkt kollegen seien also auch
polizeibeamte aber auch psychologen die
sich dann denn der bedarf besteht
natürlich um die betroffenen kollegen
dann auch kümmert ob das jetzt im
konkreten fall auch der fall sein wird
das kann ich ihn an dieser stelle nicht
sagen herr beitragen vielen herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch
dieses neue bade drama in hannover ist
leider die traurige fortsetzung von
vielen badeunfällen derzeit in
deutschland in badeseen am meer und im
planschbecken schrecklicher unfall an
einem badesee bei hannover fünfjähriges
mädchen stirbt am freitagabend hat nach
polizeiangaben ein zeuge gegen 19 uhr 15
alarm geschlagen da das mädchen beim
spielen mit anderen kindern im märchen
see im stadtteil sahlkamp plötzlich
unter wasser verschwunden sei es ist ein
schwarzer bade sommer fast jeden tag mit
einer neuen nachricht eines tragischen
ertrinkens trebur hessen am rhein kommt
es zu einem tragischen rettungsversuch
eine mutter will ihren fünfjährigen sohn
aus dem wasser holen
doch die strömung ist zu stark und reist
beide mit stunden später werden sie tot
aus dem wasser gezogen
burladingen baden württemberg am montag
fällt die vierjährige ursula in den pool
der nachbarn und verstirbt wenig später
an den folgen des sauerstoffmangels ein
nachbar passt da gerade auf das kind auf
als ursula in den pool fällt ist eher
kurzem hausen schokolade zu holen
ein ähnlich furchtbarer vorfall ende
juni in greven zwei drillings schwestern
ertrinken im gartenteich sie werden nur
zwei jahre alt
schleswig holstein hier ertrinken allein
an einem tag drei rentner zwei frauen in
badeseen ein mann in der nordsee
ahrenshoop auf dem darß dort stirbt am
mittwoch ein vater in der ostsee nachdem
er zwei kinder aus dem wasser gerettet
hatte
dabei wird matt idee selbst von der
strömung weggerissen und erst nach
stundenlanger suche tot im wasser
gefunden ein familienausflug wird zum
albtraum zurückbleibt sein zehnjähriger
sohn seine freundin susi und ihre
tochter ja worauf müssen wir beim
schwimmen achten und wie reagieren wir
im notfall richtig darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit achim wiese von der deutschen
lebens rettungs gesellschaft dlrg herr
wie sehr herzlich willkommen und an sie
die frage man hat das gefühl dass es in
diesem jahr kurzem sommer schon so
zahlreiche badeunfälle gegeben hat
entspricht das auch ihren zahlen den
zahlen den sprit das im moment noch
nicht sondern das ist in der tat ein
gefühl das man berechtigterweise hat es
ein subjektives empfinden jetzt verzeiht
können wir glücklicherweise noch nicht
davon sprechen dass das nun dass die
zahlen dramatisch oder schnell in die
ungesunde unübersehbar in die höhe
gesprungen sind wir befürchten das
allerdings für den gesamten zeitraum des
sommers da muss ich ihnen recht
immer wieder trifft es kinder wie können
wir sie besser schätzen also kinder
alleine am wasser zu lassen ist schon
mehr als grob fahrlässig insbesondere
kleinkinder kleinkinder bis zu einem
alter wissen nämlich dass es sichere
schwimmer sind darf man grundsätzlich
nirgendwo alleine am wasser lassen und
sei es der pool im garten oder dieser
aufblasbaren tools die man sich auf dem
balkon oder auch auf die terrasse
stellen kann oder eben an einem badesee
beziehungsweise auch an der küste nord
oder ostsee
ich muss ein kind immer so dicht an mir
dran haben dass ich sofort zugreifen
kann sollte ich bemerken dass das kind
in not gerät das ist und muss den
menschen und insbesondere auch den
eltern klar sein wie erkenne ich denn
einen notfall an
die handle ich richtig wir haben es ja
auch in vielen fällen gesehen
gerade wenn kinder betroffen sind stimmt
man ja instinktiv erstmals zur hilfe und
auch das kann aber dann zur tödlichen
falle werden
das ist richtig dass schon eine tanz
natürlichen fälle werden und das hat der
wert kann von anrufern sehr richtig
gesagt der spaziergänger dort in
hannover hat richtig gehandelt nämlich
zunächst einmal die 112 gewählt und die
rettungskette in gang gesetzt das ist
die erste erste hilfe die man leisten
kann und auch muss alles weitere
ob ich nun selbst ins wasser gehe und
den menschen der dort in not ist retten
kann und will
da muss ich mir eine ganz klare frage
beantworten können kann ich das schaffe
ich das bin ich dazu in der lage
wenn ich diese frage mit ja beantworten
kann ja dann versuche ich natürlich mein
bestes zweifle ich oder vielleicht
könnte ich es schaffen dann lasse ich es
dann gucke ich auf andere menschen dort
in der umgebung sind die helfen können
oder ich suche nach gegenständen die ich
dem ertrinkenden zu werfen kann und auf
jeden fall bleibe ich immer dort damit
ich den eintreffenden rettungsdienst
auch ein weisen kann wo denn die
betroffene person im wasser ist eingangs
sprachen wir ja über die kinder die es
so oft trifft folgende szenerie die
kinder spielen mit schwimmflügeln einem
seichten wasser ist das schon eine
gefährliche situation oder darf man sich
da als elternteil auch mal entspannen
als elternteil entspannt niemals und da
haben sie zwei dinge angesprochen also
nämlich einmal zum zum einen die kinder
vorne am wasser alleine spielen lassen
das zweite die schwimmflügel die
schwimmflügel sind hinterlegt und können
sogar wenn das kind im wasser liegt zur
lebensgefahr werden nämlich weil der
kopf der schwerste teil eines kindes
nach vorne fällt und eben durch die
schwimmflügel nicht also der kopf nicht
aus dem wasser heraus ragt und das kind
atmen kann also es würde auch mit
schwimmflügeln möglicherweise ertrinken
und vor allem sind sie und das ist
glaube ich jedem klar der irgendwann mal
schwimmen gelernt hat in unserem alter
sind sie auch hinderlich nicht
lernen auch beim schwimmen selbst also
auch hier besondere vorsicht mit kindern
egal wie tief das wasser ist und egal ob
sie mit schwimmhilfen ausgestattet sind
herr wie sie ich danke ihnen sehr
herzlich für dieses gespräch
wir haben diese sendung begonnen mit der
schlimmen serie von badeunfällen die
sich derzeit in deutschland immer wieder
ereignen
und während wir hier darüber sprachen
ereignete sich ein weiterer dramatischer
unfall wie sich mir gerade zugetragen
hat hier in dieser meldung die ich ihn
vortragen möchte in hückelhoven in
nordrhein westfalen ist ein elf jahre
altes mädchen nun gestorben
auch nach einem badeunfall sie konnte
offenbar nicht schwimmen
ihre freundinnen haben noch versucht
hilfe zu holen
aber das kam leider zu spät auch über
diesen fall werden wir natürlich weiter
berichten